so okay this novel when it was written
was sort of bold and provocative now
obviously we've moved on with this sort
of issue how important was it to capture
that initial essence so that audience
didn't go no big deal yes it was it was
her second but Highsmith second novel it
was written under a pseudonym and it
would describes a relationship a love
between two women which of course not
only frowned upon but illegal I think
when you fall in love for the first time
it's dangerous and it's volcanic and I
think Todd being such an outsider
and you know have been celebrated by you
know queer cinema around the world you
know he was the perfect person to make
it and only he could have made a film
about two women falling in love well you
sort of forget their gender it's an
impediment but another impediment to
their lovers is the age gap and the
class difference and you know and
therefore the gap between Carole's sort
of urbane world weariness her experience
versus Torres's relative inexperience I
mean my next question was this is a love
story but you forget the gender
literally the words because you you do I
mean how much protestin is that is this
is grown-up filmmaking it's nuanced
isn't it and we don't see that on the
big screen very often yes this sort of
script now and this kind of intelligence
with the plot usually is on television
now yes I mean I think I think the
conversation has changed in most of the
Western speaking world and I think if
this film would be made ten years ago
because of course it's been a labor of
love the screenplay has been around for
a long time and has taken a long time
for to get the film made but if it had
been made and viewed 10 years ago even
if it had been made exactly the same
frame by frame I think it would have
been viewed as a much more political
film but you know of course we did a
press conference and people from China
we're saying you know it's you know it
would be a difficult film for people to
see there I mean you know we've in many
parts of Africa this film will not be
seen in Russia this film perhaps will
not be seen so it's you know it's not
necessarily the fact that these two
women if falling in love same-sex
relationship it's um it's by no means
easy all around the world that's
interesting I've no idea actually never
thought of it like that
here or in the States or Australia we
might think actually it's shocking
because it is so recent and there it is
an issue still going on around the world
yeah it is but but I do think that the
Tod has made a film about falling in
love you do there Jen is a very big part
of it but it's but it's not all of the
film is that why Carroll was such a
great part to play as well the fact that
she's so composed on the outside and so
self-assured and look so glam but well
Sachi Smith is a is a gift for a further
for an actor because hi Smith and
understands absolutely that every adult
has a secret and secret to great things
to play with because they give you a
great interior life you know as an actor
this has been the year of talking about
gender equality are you bored of it are
you bored of talking about it the fact
that you know at the cinema the moment
we've got suffragette we've got Carroll
we've got Brooklyn we've got Sicario yes
we've got all these great female lead
films a good parts out there you seem to
find them other actresses seem to find
them it's about finding people that you
can work with where it's it doesn't
become the point of the film I think
it's up to the media to change the
conversation frankly to change the
language the work is there the talent is
there it has been for decades for
centuries it's about changing the
discourse around it but it's not just
the film industry it's you know it's
across all industries it's it's you you
know equal pay for equal work it's it's
it's about having access and I think
that there's a critical mass of women
talking about the film industry behind
the camera in front of the camera who
are producing who are making the work
and then it's about how how its
discussed so that an audience can enter
open arms so that audiences can have
access to it in the multiplex you know
and just finally another discussion that
sort of carries on in the media keeps
going with Oscars you're right I mean I
don't know about that I mean I think
it's it's that time of year yeah isn't
it and if you can harness that buzz and
if there's a buzz around Carol that's
fantastic because what it does is it
makes an audience excited to go and see
the film you know and that's why we all
do it and and the rest
you know of course it's great to be
recognized by your peers but it's
certainly not why you go into it but if
you're made to be feel one and one is
made to feel disingenuous if you
actually say that you know no I believe
it's true